there's 11 games for sure left this
season so we got a lot of football left
the season never stops after five games
it's been too disappointing weeks for us
but I can promise you that we'll find a
way to bounce back our team is mentally
tough we're resilient and we got a great
team coming up when we get back from
this thing so it's disappointing but
we'll stay connected and we'll find a
way to respond I trust that we've been
three and two before and made the
playoffs two years ago and if I remember
correctly the Patriots four three and
two last year and then won a Super Bowl
and so there's a lot a lot of game left
you know we've got a really good group
in there and yeah we're gonna bounce
back we're fine you know obviously you
don't want to lose two in a row at any
point but we got a big no there's a big
division one next week so we got no time
to waste that's John McVay Rams coach
followed by Jared Goff Rams quarterback
they're both referring to the next game
up after the mini by San Francisco 49ers
coming to Los Angeles but you know big
cat there was some good and some bad for
the Rams last night I want to start with
golf he threw for 912 yards this week
from Sunday to Thursday last night he
was 29 of 49 for 395 one touchdown in
one pick and part of it I think was
offensive design because guys were open
especially underneath I don't know what
the Seahawks were doing but it seemed
like on every play that Jared Goff
dropped back he had a guy wide open
somewhere 15 yards from the line of
scrimmage but he was delivering the ball
accurately and I you know I thought that
he looked better than I thought he would
because number one he wasn't getting a
ton of pressure and when he doesn't have
pressure he can carve you up yeah you're
absolutely right I thought he looked
good last night as well
the Bucs game he'll be the first to tell
you and I'm sure he said it
that was a bad game for him and that was
part a big reason for why they you know
lost because he put his defense in bad
situations but last night Jared Goff
played winning football their defense
wasn't able to hold up in the end
anybody played winning football I don't
think Jared Goff is the problem I also
the underneath stuff that you mentioned
it's so it's so interesting to see how
different the team looks with Cooper Cup
healthy and what they're able to do with
him in the offense makes you think what
would have happened last year if he
never goes down but I
the Rams offense
me is not the problem and it's not
something I'd be worried about if I was
front you know a Rams fan or on the RAM
staff especially with some of the teams
they have coming up on the schedule and
I always say this Mike it's it's it's so
funny how we perceive these losses and
when they happen if they happen
back-to-back and you go into the season
saying the Rams should beat the Bucks
they're gonna be you know almost ten
point favorites they should beat the
Bucks there they lose and everyone's
panicking well the Rams also want a
really tough game week one on the road
against the Panthers they want a pretty
tough game in a very loud environment
night game week three against the Browns
so this is how the NFL schedule plays
out the wins that you think are winds
could be losses and vice versa and if
you look at what they have coming up
they had the 49ers on the dreaded Mike
Florio Sea Rams long week 49ers short
week then at the Falcons and Bengals it
feels like they will probably win the
next three games and we'll be sitting
here saying hey the Rams are fine you
know the Rams are fine they're one of
the best teams in the NFC one guy we
didn't mention Gerald Everett had a
career night last night we saw him
plenty in the highlights that we that we
rolled and you know the the offense was
moving at will but it really sputtered
when it felt like they were gonna score
a touchdown on that final drive and then
all of a sudden the air went out of the
balloon there was a couple of
incompletions there was a delay of game
Brad Childress move by the LA Rams that
got them pushed back five yards and and
then you know Gerald Everett got it a
little closer for that last try to make
it a 44 instead of a 53 it just felt
like the Rams well obviously they
couldn't close the deal or they would
have won the game but they were moving
the ball at will most of the night and
that always will be there but big cat
the defense I don't know whether
something's up with air and Donald
physically there were stretches where he
wasn't in the game and he wasn't his
usual dominant self now there were
moments where he was blanketed by three
guys there were just a couple of times
where he he made plays but if if that
front four can't create pressure
it requires guys like to keep two Leoben
Marcus Peters to hold their receivers
longer and when those guys are pressed
they can't get it done anymore yeah I
mean Aaron Donald's hurt I'll say it I
mean I don't know if he was on the
actual injury report but he hurt his
back
against the Saints you saw him go to the
tunnel in that game a couple weeks ago
as someone who has a bad back myself I'm
not a doctor but I know those don't heal
overnight so I would I wouldn't be
surprised very Donald's not playing it a
hundred percent and while even at 75
percent or whatever you want to call it
he's one of the most dominant players in
the NFL that little bit could be the you
know the difference between getting to
the quarterback or having you know
creating a spot where your teammates can
get to the quarterback and you're right
once that front four can't get pressure
it all kind of falls apart for them
because that's what they're built on
they're built on getting pressure up
front having Aaron Donald be the most
dominant defensive player outside of
Cleo Mack and when that doesn't happen
this you see what you get he's not on
the injury report although he is injured
and we know how that goes we'll be right
back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports